الصين لم ترصد اي وفيات جديده بسبب وباء
كوفيت 19 وانخفض عدد الاصابات بالفايروس
قليلا ليصل الى حوالي 36 الف اصابه خلال
ال 24 ساعه الماضيه حسب بيانات هيئه الصحه
الوطنيه الصينيه كانت الهيئه قالت بانها
تعمل على اطلاق برامجها تستهدف من خلالها
دور رعايه المسنين كجزء من حمله تلقيح
جديده كما تعاهدت ببذل جهود اضافيه
للتوعيه بفوائد التلقيح اراء البعض من
كبار السن متضاربه حول الاجراءات الجديده
التي تتبعها السلطات الصحيه في بلادهم
من الضروريه
انها سياسه حيويه وجيده
اعتقد انه يوجد بانهاء الاجراءات المشدده
اشياء مثل صفر اصابه بالكونفيد او ما شابه
ذلك هو تلاعب بالكلمات لا داعي لهذه الحيل
رفع القيود من شانه ان يؤدي الى تحسين
فعاليه الجهود والكفاءات في جميع النواحي
في المجتمع كيف يمكن ان نتحدث عن التقدم
اذا كان المجتمع غير فعال
استمعت الى اراء الخبراء واختراحاتهم بشان
تحسين اجراءات احتواء الوباء واكدت ان
لجنه المركزيه للحزب الشيوعي الصيني ومجلس
الدوله وبعاد دائما صحه الناس وسلامتهم في
المقام الاول وانه يتم تطعيم المزيد من
الناس مؤكده على تراكم الخبره لدى السلطات
الصحيه الصينيه لاحتواء الفيروس فيما
يواصل المحتجون الغاضبون الرافدون للقيود
الصحيه والذين يطالبون بهمش اكبر من
الحريه لاحتجاجاتهم في ظل القمع الذي
تمارسه السلطات ضدهم